دعم امريكي مفتوح لاوكرانيا في معركتها ضد
روسيا هو ما اكده الرئيس جو بايدن خلال
زيارته
سنبقى معكم سيد الرئيس طالما ان الامر
يتطلب ذلك صدى كلمات بايدن تردد حتى من
قبل الغزو الروسيه في اروقه الكونغرس
الامريكيه الذي يؤيد باغلبيه اعضاء حزبيه
في المجلسين الشيوخ والنواب دعم اوكرانيا
مسانده ترجمت بتمرير حزم بعشرات مليارات
الدولارات كمساعدات عسكريه وغير عسكريه
ناشد الرئيس
الاوكرانيس بتقديم المزيد منها خلال
زيارته لواشنطن في ديسمبر الماضي اؤكد لكم
ان الجنود الاوكرانيين يمكنهم ان يشغلوا
الدبابات الامريكيه بشكل مثالي الا ان هذا
الدعم السخي يواجه اصواتا جمهوريه معارضه
حيث حذر رئيس مجلس النواب كبن مكارثي قبل
انتخابات التجديد النصفي بان حزبه لن يوقع
شيكا على بياض لاوكرانيا ويربط محللون
الامر بمخاوف تتعلق بالفساد لكن حتى بعض
الجمهوريين الداعمين لاوكرانيا في مجلس
الشيوخ يلتقون ايضا مع مكارتي بشان المده
الزمنيه لهذا الدعم مثل السيناتور تادي
كروز
حسنا يجب ان يخسر بوتين لكن الكونجرس لن
يمنح اوكرانيا شيكا على بياض الى الابد
موقف لا يتفق معه الديمقراطيون حسب ما
اوضحت السيناتور
على بياض لاوكرانيا دعمناهم محاولين توفير
الاسلحه التي يحتاجونها وهم مستعدون
لاستخدامه في هذه المعركه
بدورهم انتقد زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس
الشيوخ متمكن المن وصفهم بالعدد القليل من
اعضاء حزبه المعارضين لدعم اوكرانيا مؤكدا
ان غالبيه الجمهوريين في الكونجرس تدعم
استمرار المساعده لاوكرانيا وتقديم المزيد
لها حتى تنتصر
انه يبدو لم يفعل ما يكفي بسرعه لو كان
يتحرك بسرعه اكبر لربما تمكنا من مساعده
الاوكرانيين على تحقيق نجاح اكبر لكن يبدو
انظمه الاسلحه تصل بعد فوات الاوان
الكلمه الفصل في دعم الكونغرس لاوكرانيا
تكمن في مواقف قادته ورؤساء اللجان وكبار
اعضائها حيث يبدو واضحا تاييد الحزبين بل
وتزايد المطالب بتزويدها بطائرات مقاتله
بعد الاعلان عن ارسال دبابات لها
حسين الطرد العربيه واشنطن